the Joe Rogan experience what's going on
with the Mormons now is are they moving
out of there now are they gonna go back
to Utah just take one wife
that's it it all started out with right
yeah well the fundamentalist group and
they they went down there and kind of
proceeded with their customs I'm in
contact with with a few of the members
of that family and you know cut was in
contact before but when I went on here
they kind of like one of them reached
out hmm what's going on so I was out
what do we need to do yeah and then you
know it was like a friendly hello from
them from past interactions and then
this happened and you know I kind of
advised a little bit but that's you know
it's it's a mess a lot of a lot of
they're leaving the communities down
there there's a lot of them down there a
lot of communities in Sonora
kalila and you know that leaving is
leaving the area it's just too dangerous
yeah it only makes sense I mean they
just don't have the arms they don't have
the tactics and power and and they're
also in the middle of one of the most
important regions in Mexico right now
for a lot of reasons
main thing there's two things that are
really really kind of happening in that
region one the traffic the trafficking
of fentanyl and heroin and all these
drugs through one of the main drug
routes up into the u.s. and there's a
few factions fighting over that region
los Salazar which are a small cartel
faction that has allegiance just to see
in lower cartel and the Lee Nia cartel
which is historically been in control of
Ciudad Juarez so they're both kind of
buying for control of the area a few
hours before the the massacre actually
took place there were a bunch of
firefights between these two factions in
the area so one of the main theories is
that these the this group of Mormons
basically were case of mistaken identity
kind of driving into some of the areas
where they were being protected by some
of these people it's one theory right
the other thing that people kind of need
to think about is that the largest my
noble my noble deposits of lithium on
the planet right now are a few hours
away from where that massacre took place
really yes and that is you know not
conspiracy theory or theorizing here but
it's a pretty important thing in that
region and there's a lot of interest in
that space and control for that space
and they're not mining it currently
there's a bunch of projects in play
right now
so they've identified the deposits yeah
you know people can look up the numbers
but it's it's the largest my novel
deposit of lithium on the planet well
and there was some sort of deal in the
past where a Canadian mining agency was
going to have rights to it and the
mining agency was bought by the check by
Chinese company so again after that
Massacre and a lot of things happened a
lot of the negotiations happened that
problem that deal was one of the things
that got killed after that situation oh
no all right so it's it's it's an
interesting area there's a lot of things
happening there that's got to put a
tremendous amount of pressure on the
cartels in somewhere right well
historically any sort of any sort of
mining operation usually has industry
around it which is perfect for the
cartels you know extortion protection
rackets feeding the the drug use in the
area from the workers you know that's is
there any way that you could see in the
future the cartels being extracted from
the positions of power that they're in
now I mean or is this something the
people in Mexico are gonna have to live
with forever and I guess people in the
United States as well or is this
something that could be fixed you you've
you've talked about before in some of
your podcast and I listen to them a lot
great podcast
great you're on - thank you you talk
about legalization and how that would
help
that definitely is part of the solution
and it is it is definitely part of the
solution legalizing some drugs you know
not all drugs are made the same
maybe not fentanyl you know yeah but
that would help out some things there's
there's multiple things that could be
done to guide us towards a place where
things could stabilize down there
and a lot of it is not going to be able
to be done in Mexico it's gonna have to
be done up here right basically you know
when you you have to take care the u.s.
has to take care of the drug market up
here the illegal drug market and certain
things that have happened like
legalization of marijuana marijuana some
place up here have changed the dynamics
of what happens down there some for the
better some for some bad some bad things
have happened
talking to my friend John Norris who was
on here as well and comparing notes
seeing how a lot of the drug work rose
there or up here the pot the illegal pot
grills are up here exactly like the ones
that I found in Baja six seven years ago
and how some of that drug money made
from those fields are staying in the
u.s. it's not being sent back so that
means you have an active growing cartel
presence in the u.s. that is us-based so
I think that one of the the problems
that people have is perception is that
that's a Mexican problem it's a it's a
us-mexico problem you know you have
border there but the problem has two
root causes right social economic
inequality and destabilization and
corrupt government down there and a
thriving illegal drug market up here and
you know those two have to be solved to
set me in a combined way
[Applause]